good morning everybody today we are here
with Commissioner Yin as an arch who is
in charge of crisis management the
Commissioner will make a short statement
following which we will entertain a few
questions Commissioner please good
morning in these challenging times when
the whole world is struggling with the
novel coronavirus I am particularly
pleased that today I can announce a team
of European doctors and nurses from
Romania and another one from Norway to
be deployed to Italy we all know for
some time that Italy has been struck by
this virus particularly hard we also
remember that initially there was
inadequate response to the Italian
request for assistance from other EU
member states but things have changed
now and the reality is that Italy is not
alone the reality is that Europe stands
in solidarity with Italy so through the
European Union's civil protection
mechanism today these two medical teams
are being dispatched to Bergamo and to
Milano two cities that have been hard
hit by the outbreak they are going there
to help their Italian colleagues in
their bitter fight against this outbreak
next to this I would also like to
mention that Austria has offered over
3,000 liters of disinfectant to Italy
also via our civil protection mechanism
our European Emergency Response
Coordination Center has coordinated and
co-financed this European assistance it
is working 24 hours seven days a week
with all Member States to make sure to
make sure that help is channeled to
where there is most needs allow me to
recall that ever since the virus has
arrived to Europe
the Commission's number-one priority has
always been to save as many lives as
possible obviously this would not be
impossible without the dedicated medical
staff who represent the true symbol of
European solidarity therefore I would
like to thank today to Romania to Norway
and to Austria for coming to Italy's
support in a time that is so difficult
difficult for everyone for the entire
continent and the world this is European
Union Solidarity in action at the same
time I'm also pleased that Italy has
activated the European Union's
Copernicus satellite system to help them
map health facilities as well as public
spaces so as to get clear understanding
of activities including activities in
public spaces
during the coronavirus emergency last
but not least yesterday Italy also
received a delivery of personal
protective equipment which was donated
by China to the European Union
several EU member states have also sent
protected equipment bilaterally to Italy
equipment such as masks overalls and
ventilators on their own some others
have been taking Italian patients for
treatment in their hospitals in their
countries meanwhile the number of cases
in Spain has surpassed those in Italy we
are conscious of that and we are working
on that too
there will soon be a delivery of
personal protective equipment through
the Union civil protection mechanism
equipment that is being donated by
Taiwan we are in this respect in touch
with the spanish authorities all in all
i'm glad that things are improving I'm
glad that assistance is coming and I'm
particularly pleased that it has now
become clear apparently but only
together and by pooling our resources we
can overcome this unprecedented
challenge thank you thank you very much
commissioner we have also received a few
questions from journalists we are trying
to pick those that give a good
indication of the general interest that
exists in Indies in this topic the first
question will come from matina study
Scribner from the New York Times can we
have an update on the European Union's
stockpiling of protective personal
equipment when will it be available and
how will it be distributed to member
states we are working intensively on
setting up the European Union capacity
of medical equipment the so-called
rescue we have already signed the first
contract the first EU member state to
host this European capacity is going to
be Romania the contracts have been
signed the first batch of equipment
ventilators has been ordered and it is
now up to the supplier to deliver it I
would not want to speculate how much
time the supplier will need to do that
but we are expecting it soon we are also
in touch with some other member states
who have shown preparedness readiness to
procure and host the medical equipment
for the rescue
European reserve and we are advancing
with some of them as fast as we can
q commissioner the second question will
come from Jose Jimenez from the Spanish
news agency FF I would like to know if
you foresee a date for the arrival in
Spain of the medical equipments to be
acquired by public procurement do you
know if the orders have already been
placed and the contracts signed do you
think the Commission should have more
competences in crisis management in the
future and not only a role of
coordinator as you know the Commission
has launched for joint document
procedures and some of them are nearing
completion it will now be up to the
Member States who participated in this
joint procurement to place the orders
with the suppliers that were selected
and thereafter for the suppliers to
deliver the ordered goods again it
depends both on Member States and the
suppliers to do this fast and it depends
on them how fast they will do it and how
many days it will take for the first
medical equipment to go to member states
including to Spain
as for the competences it is clear that
health measures that civil protection
border management things like that these
are competencies of Member States and
the European Union European Commission
plays supportive and coordinating role
so we try to do our best but you should
not lose sight of the fact that these
are the competencies of Member States we
try to have them act in coordinated and
aligned manner we are doing our best as
for this to be changed you know that
this would involve treaty changes and
this is a long and not an easy process
so we have to do with what we've got and
we're trying to do that to our best
ability q and the last question will
come from micro peel from the Financial
Times
there have been reports from EU
countries including Germany and France
of corridors of medical equipment being
seized and diverted to the US has the
Commission investigated this problem
and if so what is its understanding of
what is happening here in particular is
this simply a case of us customers out
bidding European customers or do the
Commission and Member States believe US
authorities are directly or indirectly
causing these cargoes to be diverted we
are aware of such reports we do not have
investigative powers so that we would
investigate this kind of reports but we
are especially aware of one fact there
is a global scramble for personal
protective equipment for other types of
medical equipment because there is a
challenge for everyone involved
this virus has spread faster and further
than anyone expected this has resulted
in a shortage of supply and increase the
medical increase in demand and when you
have that it's difficult it's difficult
to arrange that an orderly orderly
procurement and especially it's not easy
to arrange it the medical equipment goes
to those who need it most
the fact is also that there are very
many out there who need it very badly
and the number may even increase that's
why the Commission is trying to mitigate
the impact of this kind of situation
when you have such severe imbalance
between the demand and supply that's
where the Commission has conducted
intensive efforts to stimulate European
production of medical equipment to
increase the supply of this equipment it
has launched for joint procurement
procedures it is pending further joint
procurement procedures because that also
helps to pull all those who need this
equipment together and and conduct a
joint procurement process and finally
the Commission also decided to to set up
European capacity once it became clear
it became clear that there is a general
pan-european problem in the supply of
medical equipment
this became clear at the end of February
early March when there was a lack of
response to Italian requests as you know
situation has improved since but the
Commission immediately immediately
started to work on creating such
European capacity for that we needed to
expand our legal basis for that we
needed agreement by member states
regarding mid-march and then on March 19
we had all things in place for creation
of such capacity we are now working on
that and we are advancing we already
have as I said signed the first contract
and we expected a delivery of first
items in the coming days thank you very
much
with that our press event has come to an
end thank your commission for coming
down and briefing us on the latest and
thank you for all the viewers for being
with us have a great afternoon thank you